[Music]  we have a terrific show tonight as i  said  can i ask you something yeah  why is dionne in the timeout corner  okay well that's uh that's simple uh  andy i i i i put him there okay yeah why  well uh why don't you tell everyone dion  why i put you in the timeout corner  i tried to make a harlem shake video at  work today  i get it yeah  i get it  that's right dion made the mistake of  trying to make a harlem shake video at  work and uh  take a look at what happened  astronaut you're fired  fired  bunny out fired  you're fired  what are you a pillow fire get out  you can stay  fired you're fired  [Music]  now dion what did i tell you about  harlem shake videos  you said harlem shake videos are the  main cause of our country's cultural  more and financial decay  and what else did i tell you  it was already old when the today show  did it three weeks ago okay well good  dion i'm glad you learned your lessons  [Music]  [Applause]  no  [Applause]